unas elecciones tan extensas como
polémicas cerca de 18 millones de
personas fueron llamadas a las urnas
para unas elecciones presidenciales
celebradas en los territorios
controlados por el gobierno y que han
sido tachadas de farsa por buena parte
de la comunidad internacional
pero como estado no nos importa en
absoluto las declaraciones de los países
occidentales más allá de lo que dice el
gobierno es importante lo que dice la
gente creo que lo que hemos visto
durante las últimas semanas fue la
respuesta suficiente y clara para todas
esas personas y demuestra que el valor
de sus opiniones es cero y su valor es
diez ceros mientras que bachar al-assad
quiere mostrar normalidad en su gobierno
la onu que intenta adelantar un proceso
de paz en siria criticó que no se
permitiera la supervisión internacional
en el clip uno de los últimos bastiones
opositores muchos manifestaron en contra
de estas elecciones
sirios y exiliados en alemania también
demostraron su rechazo a la casi segura
continuidad de al asad en el poder lo
que les hace perder la esperanza de
reencontrarse con sus seres queridos
desaparecidos
wang seca nylon de hope that perdí la
esperanza de que mi papá regrese pronto
porque mientras al asad esté en el poder
esto significa que mi papá y otras
130.000 personas seguirán detenidas y
desaparecidas por la fuerza
tanta fue split en la vida bachar
al-asad subió al poder en el año 2000
sucediendo a su padre hafez al-assad
quien gobernó siria desde 1971 desde
2011 el país ha estado bajo la sombra de
una guerra civil iniciada tras la
represión de los deseos de democracia de
una población inspirada en los
levantamientos en países vecinos en el
marco de la primavera árabe según el
observatorio sirio para los derechos
humanos más de medio millón de personas
han muerto desde entonces además la onu
asegura que 6,7 millones son desplazados
internos y 5,6 millones están refugiados
en el extranjero